Chris: ALRIGHT GUYS.
IT'S TIME FOR COUCH TIPS.
COUCH TIPS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: COUCHSURFING.COM IS A
WEBSITE THAT HOOKS TRAVELERS
AROUND THE WORLD UP WITH PEOPLE
WHO HAVE COUCHES FOR THEM
TO CRASH ON. SEEMS SAFE. WHAT
COULD WRONG?
NOTHING AT ALL. THAT'S WHY THEY
HAVE A SPECIAL SECTION ON
PERSONAL SAFETY TIPS, WITH
SUGGESTIONS LIKE, IF YOU FEEL
UNSAFE, THREATENED, OR IN
MEDIATE DANGER REMOVE YOURSELF.
THANKS, SAFETY TIP.
ALSO THEY SHOULD HAVE A BOX ON
THERE THAT YOU HAVE TO CHECK
THAT SAYS, DO YOU HAVE BOTH
KIDNEYS.
COMEDIANS, I THINK YOU GUYS CAN
DO BETTER.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO COME UP WITH
AS MANY OTHER TIPS FOR TRAVELERS
FOR COUCHSURFING.COM AS YOU
POSSIBLY CAN.
60 SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND GO.
YES, APRIL.
>> NUMBER ONE, TRAVEL SAFETY
TIP.
DON'T BE A WOMAN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JIMMY.
>> DON'T USE COUCHSURFING.COM.
Chris: OK, GOOD.
POINTS. VARNS.
>> AVOID COUCHES MADE OF HUMAN
SKIN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
I HAVE TO FINISH IT THOUGH.
ONE MORE TRAVELER TO GO,
APRIL.
>> CONSIDER SAVING $50 GET A
HOTEL ROOM LIKE A GOD DAMN
ADULT.
>> OH JESUS.
>> Chris: POINTS. JIMMY.
>> YOU KNOW, CHRIS. I DON'T KNOW
A LOT ABOUT HOTEL SAFETY,
BUT I DID STAY AT A JOHN WAYNE
GACY EXPRESS LAST NIGHT.
Chris: POINTS. JANET.
>> USE A BLACK LIGHT TO AVOID
THE [BLEEP]IEST AREAS.
[LAUGHING]
>> Chris: DID YOU JUST MAKE
[BLEEP]IEST SUPERLATIVE?
>> YES, YES.
>> Chris: POINTS, FOR SURE.
YES, JIMMY.
>> BED BUGS ARE HIGH IN PROTEIN.
Chris: OK, GOOD. POINTS. JANET.
>> THAT'S NOT CHOCOLATE ON YOUR
PILLOW.
>> OH.
Chris: POINTS.
YEAH, BUT AT LEAST I AVOIDED
THE [BLEEP]IEST AREAS.
POINTS. OK, JIMMY.
>> SAVE TIME PUT A TAG ON YOUR
TOE.
YOU WILL BE MURDERED.
>> Chris: POINTS.
APRIL.
>> WE SAY IN FLORIDA, DON'T.